την περίόδο που είστε στο εθρο σταυρό που σας συντροφεύει που είναι χραγμένο στην μνήμη
σας νομίζω την τάξεια εκτός πο βέβαιως τα υπακολουθατησης βαής που τότε τούτοτα ήταν το
πιο πολύ σημαντικό γιαμένα μετα οικονομική κρίση επίσης που περάσαμε που εβλέπαμε τον κόσμο που
πάλι είχε χάσει κάποια περλουσίαλό με τημεσας μετες τράπεζες αι κάποιοι πο από τη μια
νήμέρα στην άλλη δεν είχαντα βασικά ταβασικα και λευτα λεφτά τους είχα χαθεί να χουντας
το νεριθό σταυγο και να να νιώθουν άσκημα βέβαιος που έχουντα και αυτός ήταν ο
γόλος μας να τους κάνουμε να νιώθου ότι εμείς είμαστεκείγια να σας βοηθήσουμε και αλλά
με σευασμό πω το συν άνθωπο μας ότι πρέπει ναάντοτέ να το να το έχεισ
αυτό νε το σκέφτεσε ότι ο άλλος έρχεται διότι σέχει ανάγκη υπήρχαν στιγμες που κύρια
αφότην υπαβαδόπουλου μπροστάσε αυτές τις ικώνες λίγησε βλέποντας των πόνο κάποιον ανθρώπων η οποίο δεν
είχαν ούτε τα βασικά να στηρίξουν ται συακαι εδώ και εδώ είχε πήρθε πεπτώσεις που
μας ενόχλησαν και επίσης όταν εκανομε το ταξίδι μας τότε που ακόμα ημουν στο τμημα
νέο στιγουμαενία όπου επίαμεαπθάσεις αμεσα τμημα ενέο να πάγουμε βοήθεια στηγούμαενία τότε μ αμέσως το
είναινύντα που ήταν ι αλλαγή του καθεστότος και να πάρουμε οικωσει το όνου σποκτοκάγια στηγουμανεία
που εστείλαμε με πλίο και επήγαμε και εμείς με διάφοργα λα πράματα ρουχισμό και άλλες
αλη βοήθεια που επαίρναμε και όταν είδα με την κατάσταση που υπήρχεστα νόσοκόμα στα οφανότοφία
πραγματικά